[Music]
shaggy
and scooby were taken your
shaggy was astounding and i'm wondering
how you found the voice i mean i could
only
dress up as a character i couldn't find
the voice the way you did so what was
your process for finding that voice
that is so nice of you to say and very
nice to hear because it's
it's hard not to get in my head about it
uh it's such an honor to get to play
this character but
but shaggy has meant so much to me and
so much to so many people that
that it's a it's a kind it was kind of
terrifying
because i you know such a huge fan of
casey kasem and
yeah miller did such an amazing job too
so
but my voice is different so it was just
you know
trying to figure out a way to get my
my own version of it that that you know
uh that uh you know it just was
it's scary my voice is different than
theirs so i
i had to kind of do my own thing so
that's nice to
to hear that you liked it thank you it
was incredible and you got to
sort of remake a star is born you and
scoob
saying shallow so i can't remember
were you the lady gaga or the bradley
cooper in the relationship
i oh man it's so funny because
immediately when you say that uh uh you
know getting to do that
in in the movie was so fun because
i sing that song with jason sedakis all
the time so that is
it's uh our imitating life we are coming
up
on the 10th anniversary of mcgruber as
i'm sure you know
you're working on the series you're
writing the series as we speak so i
wanted to know if
who is better at solving fighting crime
and solving mysteries is it shaggy or is
it mcgruber and what would it be like if
the two of them paired up
well i'll say that that
they're probably on equal levels they
they both somehow get the job done
orthodox means but they they get the job
done
and you know who knows if they if they
got together maybe they would be the
greatest crime fighting force
of all time but uh they also could just
implode we already know we have the
marvel cinematic universe we have the dc
universe but now we have the hannah
barbara cinematic universe
i think spin officer's potential what
makes the hannah barbara universe
better than the mcu and dc
there's no better and worse in these
situations they're all
glorious in their own different ways i
mean
you know i grew up watching all these
wonderful characters that are now a part
of this movie so it was so special to be
in this movie
and get to see all these characters that
just you know like with scooby i
i was born in 1970 uh scoob
started in 1969 so it's it's just these
characters have just
been imprinted on my brain and and
have been a part of my life for so long
it was it was really fun to
to just be part of it
part of that huge cinematic universe i
can't wait to see the next one
all these characters were my buds
growing up you know and i think so many
people feel that way so it was just
really fun to to have this experience
i fully went daphne today it's so good i
really appreciate it
i don't anything like that in my closet
i was looking today i was just like this
is
i thank you but you are her but you are
her and in this movie we know what i
love
is that daphne dresses up as wonder
woman for halloween in this movie
but i wanted to ask you why is the
hanna-barbera
cinematic universe better than the dc
universe and the marvel universe
i don't think you can get this kind of
team together and you know i
i first of all scoob
i mean you put a dog in the center of
anything and it's better
true that is true i don't know if you
grew up watching scoob like i did
i was obsessed and i loved seeing this
world i know you have a daughter as well
like why do you think
this story has endured so much time and
span so many generations and now a whole
new generation is going to find this
movie
i think we all have a mystery i'm i
always i mean the podcast mystery
podcast the dateline
like everything is so it's just
really fun to watch people figure out a
puzzle
and come to a conclusion and this is
what they do and i think well for me as
a kid
i love the mystery the ghost stories um
kind of mystery aspect to it i
never got too scared because i felt safe
with them with this
with this group of amazing kids
and i think that's probably what is so
um what is so a part of this legacy
that's so important is that people see
that this is
really amazing group of people who love
each other and they're
loyal and kind to each other and and
funny
and everybody's got their own shtick and
their own thing
but they always come together in the end
because you know they love each other
and they want to solve mysteries and i
just think it's super fun to watch
like you know this is no exception this
is just a re-emergence
and we get to see different characters
come in
and we just you know everything needs an
update i've been sitting here
coming up with a song for you guys
because i realized it was like ken and
play dino mug and d d i was like
wrapping it
up you feel me right ken oh i have the
melody y'all are doing this
y'all are feeling it when you do that
huh i love it
well on that no you guys are so
fantastic in the movie and but you're
not part of the mystery squad so i'm
already seeing
a spin-off series would that not be
fantastic
one you know what hey you know what i'm
mad at it
i was just i i ain't angry either kersey
i think that'd be great
you got like dd you got dynamed you got
brian the blue falcon
and we go on the road we form a band
and then we'll just like spread our joy
through music
oh we go mysteries using the theme song
that you came up with
yes there you go you can lease it out
i see it captain caveman can get put out
here
join us for a cameo he he's going to
produce all our tracks
and i just it's just to me then we go on
this massive tour
opening for cold play just to get our
you know just to get used to being on
the road together
i see it in my head
i think the whole thing just writes
itself you know yeah
right right yep um so
for for you can dino dinomond
did you have to do in-depth research or
do you feel that dino met always sort of
lived inside you and you just had to
like bring him to the forefront
i had to i built a robot dog
i'm glad you brought it up i had gadgets
i had i had widgets i just
then i just um i i studied i
i i went to robot college and then
got an online degree and then i got a
puppy and then i studied that puppy two
together
and then in the meanwhile in between i
was just rolling out tracks just rolling
out tracks just throwing a lot of time
and i love that you got the mic you're
like all set up yeah just rolling it out
rolling it out rolling it out
and um it was really nice to play an
authoritative character for once kind of
kind of a comedic straight man if you
will i mean i think dede and dynamite
are almost like
kind of like de facto parents of brian
falcon played by
you know mark wahlberg so it was a
lovely dynamic so
so much joy to be a part of yeah and
kirsty for you
i mean there's so much like there's a
lot of there's like a theme of sidekicks
in this movie do you have anybody in
your life that would all
either be like your ultimate sidekick
like somebody you've never met like a
celebrity or do you have somebody in
your life
that's already a sidekick oh i'm gonna
say
my dog her name is booty she's the
ultimate sidekick
um booty like she's like like your butt
yes yes booty licious
clemens um yeah she scares off raccoons
and possums and critters
uh it's great they don't these little
animals don't come in here and eat our
garden because they know there's
booty out there watching
she's the ultimate nobody's gonna mess
with booties that's what they say
i love it i love it that's what they say
so you have voiced
and you have well you've played some
very epic
villains you have cornered the market on
villains
how is dick dastardly different
from other villains that you've played
well when i played other parts i was
trying to find something real and
emotionally grounded and subtle and
nuanced and relatable and then
along comes the original moustache
twirling villain
you know and uh and the director
encouraged me the fabulous tony savoni
who was in the booth he's the only
person you're recording with you don't
meet the other actors
to go further and further you know to go
over the top and over the top of that
and you really only scored when you made
him laugh which was ironic because of
course you can't use the take when the
director laughs in the booth
uh and so uh he's possibly
the biggest ham i've ever played
although there might be fans that would
argue
other performances were just as hammy um
i mean
i i saw a story that you told a while
back about how you found the voice for
lucius malfoy and how maybe the
producers and that weren't on board in
the beginning
how did you find the voice for this
character like you were talking a little
bit about that how you had to go
really big and at the end of the day did
you feel exhilarated did you get all the
aggression out or did you feel exhausted
yeah no it was it was a workout playing
it which is a huge character
i mean it's a huge part of the huge
character he's uh
he's king of his own domain he's created
all these
uh creatures that do well actually don't
like or respect him that much he turns
out but
he thinks they do he's a genius he's a
mad genius and he
he's built an audience for himself so
he's always on stage
he's performing all the time yeah
because there's a big hole in his heart
really
you know he's performing her muttley a
lot of the time he gets no joy from
utley
uh that that falls on deaf ears so um
we went through i did america and did
lots of different ways there have been
many dick dusters over the years
but this guy is different from the dick
dusting in the cartoons and that you're
meant to be a bit scared of him you know
he's
he is the danger he's the peril in the
movie so if he was dismissible as a kind
of pathetic loser
like dick dustin the cartoons had always
been um then there's no engine for the
plot
so i just came up with i just did a
million voices until tony went
that one right there let's do that and
then the joy of animation is you get to
re-record and record we record and play
and tweak
until everybody's happy uh and so we've
ended up with
what we ended up with they all like it i
hope the audience do too
i love it i always loved it dastardly i
watched it as a kid
and i thought that this performance was
epic but i felt
i felt that i felt the mustache twirling
as as as i was watching i mean i would
do it the thing about
would you animation do you think it's
just a voice but you're in there when
you're
addressing a crowd of thousands or
you're you know being lifted up into a
spaceship or you're beating people
on a roller coaster you do it as best
you can you might be standing on a mic
but it's a full
appallingly bad mime performance that
you're giving all the time in order to
be
to be real when i'm running from well i
can't say but various monsters and stuff
you know i'm running on the spot as hard
as i can right what i'm saying is there
was an invisible moustache
that was 12 many times i want to talk
about movie pairings this is such an
epic movie it was so much fun i had so
much fun watching it
what movie would you pair with scoob
what should somebody go and watch after
they watch school oh
my well it depends who you're watching
with i mean the great joy of this one
was you come it
it's multi-generational there's a lot of
jokes that the adults will get hopefully
the kids won't get
unless they're very advanced kids uh and
but you can watch it with
my you know i watched it with my teens
who loved it you could watch it with
much younger toddlers so it works on
on several different levels so it
depends who you're watching it with
uh and then what you would then pair it
with you want to have huge contrast
do you want to go for something
incredibly adult yeah yeah let's go for
that well you would you could do like
scuba the exorcist would you go
yes i'm jumping into that fair enough
um i don't know i i i don't think if
you've got the whole family together
multi-generational you've got to find
something else multi-generational
you can't go on with singing in the rain
love that one never never fails
doesn't matter how much my teenagers
don't like anything that was made before
2015. but uh you know
and you've got to pin them down to get
past the credits if they can see it's
not
widescreen format but uh something like
signal in the rain comes on and nobody
moves
i heard that you're a smacker so i don't
know if that's true if you got into
character by
snacking and if so what would you
recommend people
pair with watching this movie what kind
of scoob snacks are you recommending
there really is no no wrong way to
scoob snack it i mean i
i feel like the the other day we were
we were doing uh uh some
press and that we put together a huge
scoob sandwich that was like a bunch of
meat
on one level and then gummy worms and
twizzlers and stuff
and then a hot dog and it was just so
that might be overdoing it but to
actually
for for a what i will say what i will
suggest
would be some kind of like a a turkey
sandwich
or a chicken sandwich with uh
with just some simple corn chips or
doritos on top for some
for some crunch for me it's gonna be
pita chips
cheddar bunnies always been my scooby
snack of choice
popcorn probably some m m's mixed in
you gotta go you gotta get everything if
you could personally
team up with only one member of the
mystery squad
to fight crime and save the world who
would it be and why
which character it would be scoob
because i
um i think he's unassuming people don't
much but he's got he's got a whole lot
of surprises
um he's loyal and well they all are
and he will do what you say and you know
you guys
it's he he sticks by you
and he's funny and he'll never forget to
eat i'll never forget to meet a snack
i'm gonna say dino well i mean we're
part of the mystery squad now right yes
technically i'm gonna say dino but yeah
i'm i'm gonna say dd because yeah i
think we're a good team i think we're
just
a good team you know if it ain't broke
don't fix it
we're a winner no need to do
trades or free agency we're just a team
and we're just like winning
championships
it's all about those chips and we're
winning it and then we're going to go
on a road and just show our love of
music together
multi-faceted i think you can just drop
the mic on that one i think i just will
but it's a blue yeti and it's very
fragile i don't want to do that it'll
dent it and then i got other junkets to
do
i would if i had unlimited microphone
ability oh man i'd be dropping this
hard
you